What do the best writers at The New
Yorker know that most experts don't?
Many writers think that to write well,
they need to dumb down their ideas. But,
after 10 years teaching writing to
scientists and engineers, I've found
that the best science writing comes down
to four storytelling principles that I'm
going to show you in this video so you
can steal them right away. Here's how
Siddhartha Mukherjee uses them. Now, in
case you don't know, Mukherjee is a
cancer physician and arguably one of the
best science writers alive. The article
is called the science of identity and
difference. It's about the field of
epigenetics, about how genes get
switched on and off. But, if that sounds
boring, notice that the word epigenetics
isn't actually in the title. It isn't in
the opening. The article doesn't promise
to explain epigenetics. The entire piece
is driven by a single question, and
that's the first storytelling move, and
one that most writers skip. Most writers
begin their essays with a topic, but
writers at The New Yorker start
somewhere different. In this article,
Mukherjee could have written about a
topic like genetics, and eventually he
did, but it wasn't in an article, it was
in a 500-page book, which just goes to
show how bloated a topic can be. Now, he
could have written about a more specific
topic within that field, like the
nature-nurture debate, or he could have
written about his own family and how
epigenetics fits in with that personal
narrative, like a memoir. And that
relates to epigenetics because his
mother and his aunt were identical
twins. Instead, Mukherjee picks one
question that threads all these topics
together, which is why are identical
twins alike? Now, why does he start with
a question? And why should you start
your next essay this way? Well, when you
begin with a question, it allows you to
include things that would otherwise be
considered digressions. So, in this
article, using that question, "Why are
identical twins different?" that allows
Mukherjee to go into these vivid
episodes about a researcher named
Waddington and his politics during World
War II. We learn about the hunger
winter, which is when German troops
banned food exports in 1944,
and even lets him include an episode
about experiments on a cast system of
ants. And this is quite a mosaic of
episodes, but the point is that in any
other article, these would be considered
digressions because they don't clearly
relate to the topic of epigenetics. But
in Mukherjee's article, they stay in the
piece because each one helps us answer
the question. A topic gives you a pile
of things to say, but a question gives
you a reason to say them. And when
you're writing nonfiction, especially
about abstract subjects like science and
ideas, then you can try this approach.
So, for example, if you're writing about
climate policy, then you've got a topic.
But let's say you write about why a
certain town voted against solar panels
that they had paid for. Well, now you've
got a question. And that question can
become an interesting article. But if
all you've got is a topic, then what
you're going to write is basically a
Wikipedia entry. But when you switch the
focus of your article from a topic to a
question, there is a downstream
consequence that you don't want to miss.
Unlike a topic, a question forces you,
the author, to make judgment calls. And
we see this with Mukherjee explicitly.
Where is this scene? So, it's in this
part of the article where he's going
over recent debates about whether trauma
can be inherited through epigenetic
changes. This is the whole idea that,
you know, if your grandmother was
traumatized, then you can inherit that
trauma through your genes. And what's
interesting in the telling of this story
is that in this part, after covering
that debate, the author, Mukherjee,
steps forward and tells us that these
claims should invite skepticism. In
fact, he calls them fantasies, which is
pretty loaded language. Now, Mukherjee
is a doctor, so of course he's allowed
to say this. We trust him when he says
this, but you might not have that kind
of credential, and that's fine. You can
back up these judgment calls by
interviewing somebody else who does have
credibility in the field, but the point
is not to skip the judgment. All stories
have their own moral universe. They're a
little bit like the Marvel universe.
There's an interior logic to the piece,
and a story without judgment is not a
story. It goes back to same problem of
being just like a Wikipedia article,
which simply transmits information
without making any value judgments.
Narrative-driven articles like those in
The New Yorker are not objective
reporting. They're colored by value
judgments, like all good stories. And
speaking of stories, don't you hate it
when movies try to deliver too much
exposition? I notice this a lot in
biopics and historical dramas. It came
up just last night when I was watching
The Social Network, but it's something I
notice in a lot of biopics like Bohemian
Rhapsody. The genre of these historical
movies kind of force the writers to cram
in this information, and of course they
try to be sneaky about it and couch this
exposition in dialogue, but it just
never works and it feels so tedious.
Well, the same thing happens in a lot of
nonfiction writing. And watch how
Mukherjee sidesteps this exposition
problem with the second storytelling
technique, which is all about using the
foreground and the background. Now, the
instinct when you know a lot about
something is to put that information up
in the foreground. You want to teach it.
You want to give definitions, give
background information, and explain
things. And trust me, as an English
professor of 10 years who's now
developing his craft on YouTube, this is
something that I have had to learn the
hard way. Now, they're not there yet,
but one day I might be brave enough to
make public my earliest videos. So, if
you want to see how bad those are, be
sure to subscribe. But trust me, your
audience does not want you to explain,
define, or teach to them. What they want
is for you to, of course, show them. So,
it's that old cliché about show, don't
tell. But Mukherjee uses a very specific
technique, which he borrows from cinema
to achieve this. Now, just watch how he
shows you what a histone is. So, a
histone, in case you don't know, is in
this article, it's a really load-bearing
idea. And you genuinely need to
understand what a histone is in order to
follow the science. So, to explain this,
Mukherjee does not break from the
narrative. He keeps the teaching
embedded in this scene, which occurs um
in a conversation between Mukherjee and
a research scientist named Alice. So,
here he is telling us about Alice's
research. And he says, "By the
mid-1990s, Alice had found an important
clue. Genes are typically carried in
long, continuous chains of DNA. One such
chain can carry hundreds thousands of
genes. But a chain of DNA does not
typically sit naked in animal cells. It
is wrapped tightly around a core of
proteins called histones." To
demonstrate, Alice stood up from his
desk, navigated his way through the
stacks of books and papers, and pointed
out a model, a long plastic tube
cerulean blue, twisted sinuously around
a series of white discs like a python
coiled around a skewer of marshmallows.
A python coiled around a skewer of
marshmallows. With an image like that,
you will never forget what a histone is.
So, notice what happened here. We're not
provided a definition of the term. He
doesn't break from the narrative flow
like like a narrator hovering over
everything to explain. The story
continues, but we're just given this
jarring moment when the scientist stands
up, walks across the office, and points
at a physical model. And the author,
Mukherjee, who's Indian, colors it with
his own interpretation. I mean, it
really takes an Indian writer to think
to describe a histone as being like a
python, but that's how the information
arrives. So, when Mukherjee wants to
explain a histone, he does not dumb it
down. He trusts his readers, and
skillfully, he gives us an image that we
can grasp, which does a lot more work
than even a few paragraphs of
explanation. And what I really love here
is that the writer wasn't afraid to
choose this unorthodox explanation. I
mean, this explanation is so
idiosyncratically his. Very few writers
would have ever come up with an image
like that. It's an image that's colored
by his own subconscious and his own
experiences, and it really works. It's a
gift that only he could have given us.
But this principle about using the
foreground and the background is not
primarily about using visual language
and metaphors. No, it's about deciding
what do you put in the foreground and
what do you put in the background? What
belongs there? So, more than coming up
with vivid metaphors, the principle of
the foreground is to put things there
that you have personally seen. Like, who
did you talk to? What did you see in the
room? Is there a prop? Is there some
aspect of the office that gives us some
clue about the character of the person
you're talking to? What does the
person's face look like? And does that
reveal something about their own hidden
judgments or character? What I mean here
is that we're not just throwing in
visuals for the sake of it. Everything
should contribute toward our
understanding of the question that we
talked about in the previous point. But,
the idea is to put those visual,
relevant elements in the foreground.
Now, in the background, that's where you
put primary research, which is the
papers that you read, statistics,
historical contexts, background
information, definitions. Put that in
the back. And I stress this not because
many writers reverse it, but because
many ignore the elements that they
should be putting in the foreground.
What I mean is, many won't do the
in-person reporting at all. So, in the
foreground, all we have is research and
ideas and information. But, Mukherjee
never does this. Even when he's teaching
you about genetics, there's still a
scientist in the room, standing up,
walking across, and pointing at a model.
The information is being transmitted
through the medium of a story, and we
never break from that story for the sake
of exposition. And really, a
well-rounded nonfiction piece draws its
material from three sources: research,
interviews, and reporting. So, many
writers treat research as the most
important thing, and they never leave
their office. And the other stuff, if it
exists at all, is just window dressing.
But, in the age of AI, this is the least
important part of your writing.
Research and information is essentially
free. Your readers can get the research
themselves, but what they cannot get is
you in the room noticing the stacks of
books, the model on the desk, and the
images that you choose to describe it.
That's the value of your writing, and
the research is just there to support
it. And now for the third point, we need
to think about the reader's experience
of the text because you and the reader
experience the text in fundamentally
different ways. The writer has a god's
eye view of the whole thing. You already
know the story, you did the research,
you did the interviews, you have the
experience, you are looking at your text
from above as though you're looking down
at a map, but your reader has none of
that. Your reader's experience of your
text is a lot like somebody trying to
use a map to get from one place to
another from the beginning of the piece
to the end, and they walk along that
path one sentence at a time with no idea
what's coming around the corner. Now,
that blind spot between how you see the
piece and how they experience it is
where a lot of nonfiction writing falls
apart, and the fix here is to structure
your piece in time because time is the
dimension in which effective writers can
set up payoffs. And so, watch how
Mukherjee does this. The piece opens in
Delhi in 1942 when his mother and his
aunt were born, then we go to the '70s
when he was a child and interacting with
them, and then uh from there we go to
the present moment when this research
scientist David Allis is running his
lab, then we go back to the 1940s and we
learn about Waddington in the early days
of epigenetics, and then we are back to
the present moment, and then we go back
to 1944 to learn about the hunger winter
in World War II, and then we are in 2003
back in the United States. But notice
that every one of these major shifts in
time is accompanied by a transitional
device, a signal. By the time I was born
in 1970, one afternoon in April, in the
fall of 2003. And these are some of the
most boring phrases in the English
language, but they're doing enormous
work. They're telling your reader where
they are on the map. And see how this
works? I just need to show you this
scene at the end of it to to show you
how these payoffs work. Because you get
a scene like this, where they're walking
together in the park, his mother and his
aunt, and he's talking So, his aunt is
named Bulu. And Bulu, who's the
identical twin of his mother,
reminisced about how the vicissitudes of
their lives had reshaped her and her
sister in different ways. While I
couldn't help noting how fiercely they
had converged. In calculus, the first
derivative of a curve at any point
refers not to the position of the point,
but to its propensity to change its
position. Not where an object is, but
how it moves. This shared quality was
the lasting link
between my mother and her twin. Tulu and
Bulu were no longer recognizably
identical, but they shared the first
derivative of identity. And so that
line, the first derivative of identity,
in isolation, is a pretty clever
metaphor. But in context, after you have
moved through this entire text, after
you've seen the two sisters, you know,
being born in Delhi and having these
diverging lives and coming together at
the end, and after you've learned about,
you know, the entire development of this
field of epigenetics, that line, that
metaphor really pops. And if you haven't
read this article, then you might just
have to take my word for it. But I can
show you another way this works, as
well. Notice over here, freckles. Okay,
so he's using this line and he's talking
about
even though two twins can have the same
genome, uh chance events in their lives
can cause different expressions of their
genes. So, he says, "Chance events,
injuries, infections, infatuations, uh
da da da, they impinge on one twin and
not the other. Genes are turned on and
off in response to these events as
epigenetic marks are gradually layered
above genes, etching the genome with its
own scars, calluses, and freckles."
Freckles. Like, freckles on the genome.
That's such that that that's an image
that was planted at the beginning of the
piece twice. He hits us twice in the
opening with this image of freckles.
Now, at the beginning, he's using
freckles to say they both have the same
freckled skin. And he's looking for the
precise map of freckles on her face. It
It's the scene where one aunt They're
playing a trick on the kid. They're you
know, it's the
She's pretending to be the mother
talking to the son and trying to see if
he'll notice that they've swapped each
other. And so, in order to figure out
which one he's talking to, he's looking
for these precise markers, the freckles.
But now, this image, which has already
been established at the beginning, is
being used at the end to tell us the way
that these epigenetic marks are. So,
it's just wonderful the way that image
was developed at the beginning and then
used to pay off at the end. And that's
something that you can only get by
carefully structuring the layout of
time. It's the kind of payoff at the end
of a piece that's not possible without a
setup, and you can't have a setup
without orienting your reader in time
along the way. And for the last move,
whenever you are writing about something
that you care about, like, of course you
think it's important. But the question
is, how do you get your readers to care
about it? Well, to get concrete, readers
of the New Yorker might be educated and
perhaps familiar with the field of
epigenetics, but we never assume that
they're primarily interested in it.
Otherwise, they'd be reading a
scientific journal. So, we have to
assume that your reader does not care
about what you care about. That's where
we have to begin the writing because
consider the opposite. If you assume
that readers share your values, then
you're preaching to the converted. You
see this is used everywhere in writing
about the environment. Words like
sustainability, diversity, and progress
are deployed as though they're
self-evidently good. And maybe they
should be, but if your reader already
agrees with you, then what's the point
and what's the value of your writing?
Your article does the work of moving
somebody onto your side. Here's how
Mukherjee does it. He knows that readers
of The New Yorker don't automatically
care about epigenetics. So, what do they
care about? Well, they care about
families. They care about immigrants.
They care about two women born in Delhi
in 1942. So, that's where he builds the
door into this world of epigenetics
through a family story. By the time
we're in a lab looking at histones,
we're already on his side. We care about
what he cares about. And I have to point
this out because I think he pulls this
off in a way that's just so subtle, but
so effective. At this point in the
article, he introduces an experiment on
ants. And this is important to our
understanding of certain genes and how
they get turned on and off by the
environment. But this story, you could
imagine, could have been a pretty dry,
technical digression, just reporting on
a science experiment, very far from the
human story that we've been tracking.
And so, watch what Mukherjee does here.
He describes the colony of ants using
the word cast. Now, that one word
imports everything from the previous
episode about his family, Indian
society, where the story began, and the
emotional stakes. All of it gets
hyperlinked into this scene about the
experiment on ants. And this is a
fantastic move whenever we're trying to
engender our values in the reader. We
don't debate the reader into our point.
We don't persuade them. We need to build
them a bridge from where they are, what
they currently care about, onto what you
want to show them. The readers of the
New Yorker cared about family, and they
cared about the caste system. So,
Mukherjee uses this language from that
world to describe what could otherwise
be a pretty inhuman scene. And we see
this kind of empathy as well whenever
Mukherjee is describing
uh the research scientist Alice. You
know, he doesn't just report on the cold
facts of his experiments. He tells us
that Alice is ruthlessly self-effacing
in a way that his colleagues find
endearing. He tells us that Alice had a
fraternal twin who was more studious and
in whose shadow he grew up. And this is
a great passage because it seems like a
digression at first, but it just
contributes so much to our understanding
of the scientist and the questions that
he's asking. So, it says, "As a child,
Alice grew up in the leeward shadow of
his sister, a fraternal twin, in
Cincinnati. She was the studious one,
the straight-A student. He was the
popular kid, the high school fraternity
president, casual about his schoolwork.
We were similar but different," Alice
said. "At some point in college, though,
Alice's studies became a calling rather
than a chore. In 1978, having obtained
his Ph.D., Alice began to tackle a
problem that had long troubled
geneticists and biologists. If all the
cells in the body have the same genome,
how does one become the nerve cell and
say another a blood cell, and which
looks and functions very differently.
So, in one sense, this little story
might look like a digression or just
some kind of character development, but
in another, it contributes a lot to our
understanding of the research question
that he devoted his life to
understanding, which is why cells become
different from one another. The
principle is one that you've heard
before, show, don't tell, but the
execution, the way that Mukherjee pulls
this off, is harder than it might sound.
If you tell your readers that a
researcher is passionate, that's a
label, but if you're like Mukherjee, and
you tell your readers that a researcher
scored an A- minus in his first
biochemistry class in college, but felt
that he hadn't really mastered the
material, so he applied to take the
class again, well, that's not just a
label, that's a character. And so,
whenever you're writing about science or
ideas, you know, these pretty abstract
subjects, it's important to remember
that these characters are everywhere.
Science does not happen on its own.
People do science. They run studies,
they ask questions, they make decisions.
So, whenever you interview somebody,
don't just interview them as a source of
information. Interview them as a human
being who's pursuing their own motives.
Ask them questions like, how did you end
up spending your life studying this
topic? Or ask them, what was your most
important experience? Those questions
will open doors that fact-gathering
never will. And just keep in mind that
the people in your story are not only
the experts, they're also patients,
homeowners, students, neighbors, anyone
who lives inside the world that your
question opens up. Because if your
reader can see people, they'll follow
you anywhere, even into epigenetics. But
essays like this only work if you have a
strong opening, because if your reader
doesn't make it past the first
paragraph, it doesn't matter how good
the other ones are. So, watch this video
next because it's going to show you a
three-part system for introductions
that'll keep your readers hooked. So, be
sure to go check it out.